[Music]
follow the light how do you feel Daniels
fine any dizziness nausea fine it's a
hell of a viewing it it is pure majesty
I don't know what you're talking about
kind of spooks me out some big old
seeing nothing quietly will commence in
153 minutes a lot one hour before taking
the purgative and please ensure to
consume the requisite liquid and vitamin
back I just wanted to say hey before I
jet at him feeling kind of crazy well
you know feeling good I'm just burning
up I thought we're gonna have one more
drink before he went into cryo sleep
who's gonna lead us at our toasts said
Dan do Samus you know what to say all
right captain make sure your own vase oh
yeah you get on me all right
hey captain
is he gone yep let's party
I got 2,500
okay Birds non-stop whoo I'm trying to
eat oh come on this is barely food but I
love is the last I'm gonna have this
meatloaf
I'm in this grandma's apple pie yeah how
they move miss barbecue nachos okay down
the wrong pipe
I've got your back oh that was a joke
right yeah so what about that speech
Daniels I have prepared I'm sorry yeah
Jake asked me to say something that's
okay please
you've all sacrificed so much to be here
to be a part of this it's the first-ever
large-scale colonization mission to come
this far into our galaxy making history
everyone back on earth who's really
grateful for your hard work and your
courage I just want to say I couldn't
pick a better bunch of jerks to get
marooned on a distant planet with so so
the continents
[Music]
camera speeds open I can do this the
fictional
you
there was a very strained and they said
II wonder
[Music]
you sure about this captain how do you
mean what the [ __ ] out there
[Music]
you